mental health yeah it's the silent
killer because
you don't know what someone's going
through in their head you can have these
comedians that are performing on a stage
everyone's laughing people look to my
career and they're like
dan's great it's like no i was seems
terrible that's the worst time of my
life
and that can be anyone you know at any
point on any level and it's that thing
where you have to go how are you doing
and then you have to ask again like no
no how are you really doing because
people they don't want to
they feel like they don't want to burden
you they feel like they don't want to be
judged they don't want to feel
vulnerable but the truth is
we all go through the same things our
human experience is universal
if you open up to someone they're going
to be like me too
probably or they'll be like wow well i
want to be here for you
thank you for sharing that with me so
firstly it's important to just cut
through the the barrier that all of
humanity has
socially with wanting to appear
vulnerable and asking for help
and then for sometimes you know when i
was feeling really bad
sometimes a friend couldn't do something
for me and that was frustrating for them
if they're like i want to help i want i
want to fix you on and make you better
and it's like actually
you know right now just being here
is the best thing that you can do
because when it comes to mental health
out any lifestyle change anything you
can learn in therapy
anything scientific the most profound
way of supporting yourself
emotionally is just feeling a connection
to others and hey i'm the introvert guy
i don't want to say this
you know i'm going to complain about how
exhausting i find it but just feeling
like
even to one person that you are seen
that so you have been acknowledged for
what you're going through
and that you're not just not alone with
your thoughts can be the thing
that is between someone and oblivion
because it's when people feel like
they are alone they're struggling by
themselves and they are trapped in a
situation that the worst things can
happen
so just having one person just being
there
can literally be a lifeline yeah they
say that one of the
most important ways to create connection
is to meet someone where they're at
absolutely
yeah yeah sometimes it's just being with
them i think that we mess that up right
so many i'm i have messed that up a
hundred million times where
i'm kind of that fix-it person like i
err on that sort of co-dependent like
how can i abandon myself to fix you
um but i you know i you know always
wanted to go in like okay what can we do
and what's next and
you know i've been learning over time
how important it is to just really be
with the person or
be be there and meet them where they're
at
and really you know create some sort of
relationship and empathy with
with the feelings that they're that
they're having
because sometimes you can't fix someone
instantly and they just need that
support and they may not even tell you
that they're grateful at the time that
maybe when they've had this
the time and the space that they need
they'll be like that really meant a lot
to me that you showed up when i needed
you
yeah you're the you're you're the
youtube guy you know you have a huge
following you're so funny i mean
first off i'm super curious who does the
edits because your videos are so
cl like they cut away to moments and you
must do a bunch of like you must spend a
lot of time not only recording
the video itself like on camera but then
the cutaways that you go to and like
who does that it's so crafty i'm
starting with the fun stuff but
um get into kind of what that led to but
i mean what the heck it's amazing it's
something that i had to teach myself
and the things i'm a control freak i
could never if something was so
important to me i don't let someone else
mess it up what i want to do
is to do everyone's job myself and then
just be really resentful but i feel like
i'm getting no help
so oh can we help you and i'm like no no
no if you want something doing right you
have to do it yourself and how do you
feel about that i hate everyone
that's me down to a t but i wasn't
always
it wasn't very slick the thing with me
is i started
just doing these funny videos on the
internet as a hobby when i was 18.
and it was just me on my little laptop
googling how do i cut clip together
and it was so bad it was so bad even
though it was your best then though but
it was your best then
but all of it is just still there on the
internet because i got these followers
and they're like oh no no
no that old stuff you did is so funny
because it's so bad
you cannot take that away from us and
i'm like can i just hide my worst stuff
so i look really cool
like no no no no you can't this is your
thing dan you just have to embarrass
yourself forever so my whole journey
from being an 18 year old with no plan
just doing it to make fun
and it was awful all the way up to what
i'm doing 10 years later it's just crazy
that my whole journey
not just as someone you know being
creative learning to edit filming and
writing or whatever
but as a person my life in real time
from
dropping out of college to moving to
london to
where i am today it's all just there out
in the world
which is a very surreal experience for
how i perceive myself
which i feel like a lot of other people
don't get um you mean because you're vul
you're you're introverted yet it's like
out there
and on people
on social media with their comments they
tell you
how they perceive you and that's
something that
you may not realize about yourself and
for me particularly with my mental
health journey
that was one of the most profound things
because i've always just had
my own view of the world which comes
from that very dark cynical
self-defensive place where i'm always
expecting the worst from everyone
and even before i started talking about
mental health in what i did on the
internet people go hey this funny video
that you made
it really made me feel better on this
terrible day and
i was going through something and you
cheered me up and i just want to say
thank you for that and
i i was literally not used to having
what was
actually just a fair view of who i was
as a person
it wasn't even endless compliments from
people it was just people just saying
hey i see you for who you actually
are here you go dan and i'm like this is
news to me so it's
only because my career
and social media and comments from
people and meeting for you know i'd go
on tour
and people would open up to me about
these things they'd be like oh this is
how something you talked about help me
you talked about mental health and then
you know i've gone on this whole journey
it's only because of what that
opportunity has given me for
self-reflection that i was able to grow
if i'm imagining a universe where i
didn't have this
i'd probably be stuck in the pit well
the first thing that came to mind is
vulnerability like you're like can't i
just take down the stuff
so like first off you were vulnerable
but then second off it makes me think of
something that you said earlier how
being like
a human being is kind of simple like
it's actually quite simple and the thing
that i've been thinking about a lot
lately is that
is that very concept that being a human
being is really simple
or being being like being a human is
simple but the experience is complicated
because
everything really everything in our
reality which you
just said is showing us who we are so
people are out there saying
i see you dan you're funny i see you
you're this you're this you're that and
it's all information about you
but yet the complicated part about being
a human
is that we can't see ourself
we literally can't see ourselves so
everything in our reality
is information about who we are and so
it can be direct like dan you're this
but it can also just it can also be
something
like you observe a situation and you
judge it or you're triggered by it
that's also just information about you
if you judge something you probably
would never let yourself
do it which is why you're judging it if
you're triggered it's probably because
you've got some
unhealed aspect of from childhood
that needs to be fixed and so it's like
yes it's like it's simple but it's
complicated
because we can't see ourselves it's so
difficult and that's why like the book
that i wrote is
separated into three parts because i was
like how do you even write a book about
mental health because it's just such a
huge topic
and i was like what we need to do is to
break it into
the experiences you can have at
different stages and when you might need
the information so the first part is
what can you do if you need an immediate
change because you're overwhelmed in a
situation so it's not about
how do i unpack my psychological makeup
and trauma or how do i change my
lifestyle it's like
if i feel like i'm having a panic attack
if i feel like i'm too stressed if i
am having one of those moments where i'm
stuck up in my head
because i'm fixated on something i'm
worrying about or this
intrusive thought came in and i can't
how do i snap myself out of it
and one of the most profound things is
just the concept of mindfulness
realizing that
you are not your thoughts because all of
our emotions
come from biological evolutionary places
where we're just cavemen
running from lightning bolts and yet now
anxiety in our modern world just comes
into this
weird thing that mixes all these
relationships together and it's like
actually what's happening to you is
something physical
and if you just breathe differently if
you just
indulge your senses try to be present in
the world
instead of being up in your head if you
just have the knowledge that you can
acknowledge a thought that may be
overwhelming you and just go
that is not a fact it's not something
that i'm feeling
it's just a conversation my brain's
trying to tell that's coming from some
kind of physical place
you can put that to the side and that
saves you in the moment and these are
the kind of basic
tools that i think every human on earth
yeah should know
because i'm someone that is just at the
absolute mercy of my mind i
bolt awake with anxiety at 4am just
going like
okay the distractions of the day over i
try not to think about things
and then you have that moment at night
where the world falls away and without
the distractions or anything
there's this moment where it's just you
and whatever you've been pushing to the
back of your mind and suddenly it goes
hi i want to talk to you right now and
it's just terrifying